back now at 7 30 and the popular trading
app
robin hood is under new scrutiny as part
of a lawsuit centered
on a tragedy the site is part of the
reason gamestop shares recently surged
against expectations
before quickly plunging again costing
many small investors large amounts of
money
it was a painful reminder for one family
of their own son's death by suicide last
june at a time when he believed
he'd racked up massive losses on the
robin hood app
we spoke to his parents who blamed the
company for his death
to be honest it was really a joyful
household it was
late last spring dan and dorothy kearns
had a full house
after the pandemic brought their 20 year
old son alex home from college
one night he says to me he's like mom i
don't i don't know what i want to do
with my life yet
but i do know i want to help people but
alex was also interested in investing
and it opened an account with robinhood
an app that lets
anybody buy and sell stocks with no fees
and no experience i didn't see the
harman doing that and it was limited
exposure so
where did he get the money that he had
from
that was grabbing grandpa money gifts
all told he might have had maybe five
grand
in the savings what the currents didn't
realize was he had also been approved by
robin hood to buy and sell
options a riskier instrument with the
potential for huge
losses i don't understand how they
allowed that to happen in the first
place
they say alex's inexperience is what got
him into trouble one night last
june when his robin hood account showed
a negative balance of more than 700
thousand dollars at 3 26 a.m
the company then sent an automated email
demanding alex take
immediate action requesting a payment of
more than a hundred and seventy thousand
dollars on his debt
he thought he blew up his life he
thought he screwed up beyond repair
robin hood has no customer service
number but alex
emailed three times to help understand
whether he could still offset the losses
with another trade
could someone please look into this he
wrote receiving back nothing more
than an automated message and their
response was a canned
reply basically we'll get back to you
later what do you do with that thought
it haunts me it really does later that
day the sheriff knocked on the kern's
front door
to deliver the news alex had killed
himself
i lost the love of my life he
i miss him more than anything
it's the kind of pain that i don't think
should be humanly possible robin hood
says its mission is to democratize
finance bringing younger and more
diverse investors into the market
and approached the company highlighted
in a super bowl ad you don't need to
become an investor
you were born one robin hood
it's the conduct and this conduct is
reprehensible
william galvin is the chief financial
regulator in the state of massachusetts
and one of robin hood's chief critics it
was a very deliberate effort on the part
of robin hood
to particularly entice younger
inexperienced
investors yeah i bet he's investing
right now
he points to the company's marketing
claiming it rewards daily usage of the
app and encourages
frequent trading a new kind of investor
is changing things up
even working in virtual confetti in what
a recent complaint by galvin's office
described as
gamification they call themselves robin
hood for a reason right right
robin hood steals from the raiders
is that what's happening i don't think
so they have not
acted in the best interest of their
customers so idea that they're caring
for the poor
is simply not true what happened to alex
kearns is a particular worry to galvin
and his team
they say they found more than 600
examples in his state
alone of robin hood customers who by the
company's own standards
should not have been approved for
options trading but were
their rush to make money out of this has
caused them to add people to their base
and to recklessly bring people on board
who they probably should have said no we
won't qualify you for options right now
we too were curious to know how easy it
is to get approved for basic
options trading on robinhood one of the
first questions is
how much investment experience do you
have i'm going to choose none
that resulted in a rejection but it's
giving me the choice here to
update my experience if i'd like to but
by simply changing
no experience to not much we got
approved
immediately welcome to options how are
those guard rails how does that
stop an 18 year old from
making risky trades that they don't
really understand in a suicide note to
his parents
alex had similar questions how was a 20
year old with no
income able to get assigned almost a
million dollars worth of leverage he
wrote
adding i also have no clue what i was
doing
he said in a note i didn't want to die
he also said that
he was doing this for us because he was
trying to save us from what he thought
was impending financial disaster
in a wrongful death lawsuit they plan to
file today
dan and dorothy kern say robin hood must
be held
accountable do you think if robin hood
had somebody
manning an email account or picking up a
phone
that alex would be here today absolutely
yeah i have no doubt
he just wanted an answer he just needed
a little help
he could have gotten answers to those
questions and there was nobody there
to do that for him it wasn't until the
day
after alex kearns killed himself that
robin hood sent an email suggesting
he didn't actually owe any money at all
robin hood ceo declined an interview
with us but in a statement to cbs news
the company said
it was devastated by alex kern's death
the robin hood said it has since revised
the experience requirements for
customers
seeking the type of riskier trades and
options that alex was trading and also
added a feature for customers in his
situation to request a call back from
the company
however it still does not have a phone
number for customers to call themselves
the company said it disagrees with the
allegations made by the commonwealth of
massachusetts
but robin hood declined to address why
it did not respond to alex kearns's
emails
the night before his death so let me get
this straight
he may not have lost any money at all
this may be a mistake in an email
it appears that he was led to believe he
was deeply in debt and had ruined
himself and his parents when in fact he
wasn't
and so at issue here and the state of
massachusetts brings this up is
robin hood is like your broker and your
broker cannot lead you to believe you
have ruined yourself if you have not
that's that's a big part of the issue
here it is a heartbreaking story but i'm
trying to figure out what is robin
hood's responsibility if you go on the
app and you sign
willingly sign and you're over the age
of 18 which makes you an adult in many
places
what is your responsibility a duty of
care to a customer
who is like a person who you're giving
financial advice to
in essence a brokered dealer
relationship it's different in each
state
but you know something the parents bring
up which i think is key is alex was too
young to go to las vegas and gamble yes
yeah but he could go on robin hood in
his bedroom upstairs
and gamble just the same a lot of
questions i want to understand i mean
basically if if this is true
then an erroneous email caused this
young man suicide
yes which is just i mean and so a key
question is
why don't they have customer service
available at a phone number's
reach and we're actually going to talk
about that tomorrow we investigate why
robin hood has
no phone number for customers to call
and we speak with former employees who
have described some of the problems that
they faced when robin hood users
needed help